who's she she's got a question for us
actually we'll get right into that but
your statement let's get this question
real quick right here from Ali
semi-related what you guys talk about
okay beautiful beautiful lady right
there and boys shocked when you see a
pretty person that's senior stand up and
you're like you saw me yeah look I get
it if you're like 280 pounds you got a
beard you're troubled yeah yeah yeah
you're like dude we all go do this our
times yeah but no when you see her
you're like huh what happened um there's
nothing off them if there's only been
one subject that Isla asked me not to
talk about but like I talked about her
period I'll get her period no special
they're pretty cool with it although I
gotta be honest with you I don't know
you know the long-term effects of it I
don't
oh sure did you know I mean not in a bad
way but you don't it's like I don't and
it's sad it's gone he's a comedian you
know saying he's dry he's fine on the
country telling people on my period I
don't you know I don't I don't I can't
imagine it's gonna be awesome like I you
know you don't put any thought into it
here's how it works is that like right
so I'm on the road with at the time it's
me Segura and Ian bagg are doing Irvine
and Brea every Tuesday every Tuesday
Wednesday right we're just banging out
Tuesday Wednesday Tuesday Wednesday not
Ontario just Irvine in Brea nice car
driving out and then one day you tell a
joke the first joke I wrote about the
girls was Isla was a babyish and she had
she would they woke up early in the
morning I go downstairs I hear my baby
mother go downstairs I'm like what's
going on why are you laughing
George's in a rocking chair I was naked
and George is like that you guys see
baby Islands Niue trick the dogs in
between them I don't [ __ ] know and I
go what is it she goes I don't want to
spoil it for you I'll show Dad and Isla
takes her finger shoves it up her ass
and puts it in the dog's mouth oh that's
the first joke I wrote about my
daughters hollyrock and it the Jolly
Roger
we call the happy Nazi and so I go and
so I tell that story on stage in both
the N and Tom are like bro that's like
that's legit funny it's not a kid joke
that's just a funny [ __ ] joke like we
don't have kids and we still like it and
that was where I flipped the switch and
so then no then eyelas maybe two or
three you're just four or five you start
writing jokes about your kids and
they're definitely not seeing it they're
not seeing at all and then I do the
Machine and I put all those stories I
have it about the girls and it starts to
work like people start relate to it I do
secret time and that's when they were
like they were like hey like like kind
of curious like what do you say about us
I was like guys it's not a big deal this
one they were like you run everything
past us first and so I had to run the
period joke pass Thailand she was hell
did you sit down and talk to her about
it I told her look I put it here's what
how you know me man I put it on [ __ ]
Instagram stories the day it happened so
the day it happened she gets her period
she wants to a period party they do that
now
oh yeah it's big time what oh yeah a
period part yeah I told part of the
story on her own and I told just a part
of the story on Conan and it got 20
million views immediately so like she
she's like I don't want to ruin it watch
this special but she I get I get all the
stuff for the period party address and
read I mean what like [ __ ] red velvet
cake you're gonna love do you love this
bit you'll love this bit but my point is
I put it all in Instagram stories that
night cuz I'm laughing I'm dying
laughing and then I get in bed that
night she comes in she's like hey big
boy I need you to take that down and I
go what I go baby it's it's it's fine I
think it's cool she was yeah I know I
don't mind people knowing I through a
period party but I don't want kids in my
school knowing I had my period yeah and
I went oh okay that makes sense so I
pull it all down and then I go to
Louisville that next weekend and I talk
about it I've tried on stage and just
that just that reaction you just had is
the whole rooms having it but the weird
part you know me I'm a meathead I'm like
a [ __ ] mouth breather
women are connecting with it going like
cheering for ila which I think so then I
work it out a little bit
I talked out about it and I was like I
want to do part of that story on Conan
and she's like she goes why I go I think
it's good I think it's a good thing I
think that the thing that you're doing
is gonna be good for little girls and
other little girls will see it and it
the trauma that Georgia with Georgia had
her period she was a [ __ ] nightmare
and I said the trauma George went
through you can help them avoid that
Kyla didn't want to go through what
Georgia went through so she just
circumnavigated and when I'm gonna
celebrate this moment right and so I
told her I'll Conan she watched as she
was cool with it but then the next day
my email gets flooded with little girls
emailing me like their parents their
parents are emailing me from their
daughters like this my daughter wants
you to once you read this and letters
coming in to my manager like hey I was
really scared about getting my period
I've been really nervous about it but I
saw your dad's story thank you for
letting him tell it and then an island
named her period and they go and by the
way we just welcome Darryl to our family
so it was so like I don't I don't have
any limits like I'll talk about [ __ ]
anything whether or not it goes into a
special it's like another thing cuz I
got her I gotta run it by them damn like
and I know it's gettin it's gettin
touchy for Georgia yeah yeah I could
imagine but yeah I could imagine that
that's a lot goin on she's 15 and when
she starts [ __ ] up and you want to
talk about it you know she's gonna be
like you imagine if you're if all your
fuck-ups oh I couldn't yeah and so it's
I don't know man I I will see who knows
maybe I won't make it out of this
coronavirus and that's the end of my
stand-up getting good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one